aspirina não é remédio para trombose
venosa Tá certo aspirina que são os
antiplaquetários um deles é aspirina Ou
clopid rogel eles eles agem nas questões
arteriais que aí a gente pode até marcar
outro dia e falar Tá certo as as
oclusões das tromboses de artéria essas
sim elas são mediadas por alterações nas
placas de cálcio hemorragia dentro das
Placas placas né formação daquelas
rolhas de plaquetas os antiplaquetários
eles são utilizados nisso para evitar o
quê infarto para evitar AVC entupir o
stente Tá ok então antiplaquetário PR
trombose venosa não é a medicação do
escolho Então se alguém eu já ouvi meu
cardiologista mandou eu tomar Aspirina
antes de viajar você só vai ter dor de
estômago não vai te proteger de trombose